In principle, of course, you know by now
how to show that a problem is NP-complete
because we have already shown this in the last unit for 4 different problems.
We have shown the NP-completeness for vertex cover,
we have shown the NP-completeness for clique,
we have shown the NP-completeness for independent set,
and then for SAT, the mother of all NP-complete problems if you will.
So for showing NP-completeness, there is always 2 steps.
First you have to show that your problem is in NP,
which means that a nondeterministic RAM
can solve your problem in polynomial time,
and later in this course we will meet some problems
actually that are worse than NP-complete problems,
so it's often a very simple step,
but it's one that you have to go through
because you might be dealing with even harder problems although that is unlikely.
And the second step was finding a polynomial time reduction
from another problem that is known to be NP-complete
using the ideas that Cook and Levin had for their famous Cook-Levin theorem.
Then we showed that clique is NP-complete by reducing SAT to clique.
And then from our first unit,
we already knew that clique, vertex cover,
and independent set are all very closely connected to each other.
So you can basically reduce these problems to each other
in any order or way that you want
because they are so closely related.
I would like to do a brief quiz with you,
which is a little bit subjective although I think you'll likely agree with me,
and what I would like you to tell me is
how difficult you found those reductions that we have encountered so far.
So showing that SAT is NP-complete,
showing that clique is NP-complete,
and then showing that vertex cover and independent set are NP-complete,
and I would like you to rank these
3 reductions that we have had so far by difficulty
where 1 means easiest,
3 means most difficult, and you can guess what 2 means.
So please rank the difficulty of those reductions that we have encountered so far.